en los vídeos pasado ya justificamos
como la curva de oferta agregada a corto
plazo era una curva con pendiente
positiva es decir que era una curva que
iba hacia arriba verdad pero todas
nuestras justificaciones se basaron en
el hecho de que íbamos modificando los
precios y con eso veíamos cómo cambiaba
la oferta entre en términos del producto
interno bruto real déjame le pongo por
acá producto interno bruto real y de
este lado lo voy a poner precios
entonces movíamos los precios y cambiaba
en producto interno bruto real pero en
realidad podemos interpretar esa curva
de otra forma moviendo el producto
interno bruto la producción o sea la
oferta de bienes y viendo como eso
modifica el precio déjame en dibujar acá
cómo estaban las cosas por aquí hasta la
derecha teníamos un cierto máximo
teórico verdad que podría alcanzar la
economía que era súper difícil de
alcanzar entonces este es el máximo
teórico lo voy a poner aquí tengo este
teórico luego tantito acá un poco más a
la izquierda teníamos la oferta agregada
a largo plazo que era el potencial de la
economía y era un nivel saludable verdad
de la economía y luego teníamos la curva
de eau
agregada a corto plazo que tendría
aunque tenía una pendiente positiva algo
más o menos de este estilo más más o
menos así así así y se iba pegando
asintóticamente al máximo teórico
entonces si ahorita estamos en una
economía
digamos saludable vamos a estar más o
menos a este nivel de precios y déjame
indicarlo por acá
entonces tenemos ahorita este nivel de
precios y justo bueno lo que habíamos
dicho es que si modificamos el precio
entonces eso modifica va de cierta forma
el producto interno bruto real porque
había una serie de factores que
motivaban a las empresas a producir más
cuando había un aumento de precios
de hecho bueno para como un pequeño
repaso vamos a acordarnos de cuáles eran
las teorías o bueno cuáles eran los
posibles modelos que explicaban esto las
posibles explicaciones entonces la
primera era la teoría de la presencia de
la percepción incorrecta que básicamente
decía que o sea yo como actor individual
si veo un incremento de precios lo puedo
pensar como un fenómeno micro económico
entonces por la ley de la oferta y la
demanda me conviene en ese momento subir
precios aunque eventualmente me dé
cuenta que las ganancias
y gané por ese aumento de precios sólo
fueron nominales porque comparado con
toda la economía pues no me van a servir
para comprar muchas cosas que será la
primera teoría y la segunda teoría era
una teoría de costos rígidos verdad o
sea esto de costos y precios rígidos
tenía que ver con que aumentar el costo
pues era sencillo pero no era tan fácil
cambiarlo en algunos contextos por
contratos y por otro tipo de acuerdos
que ya se habían hecho y entonces hay
algunos actores que les conviene empezar
a producir más porque ellos sí pueden
cambiar su precio rápido y seguir
recibiendo este pues su inventario y su
material este para hacer las cosas de
una manera más barata bueno entonces eso
era más o menos dos razones para
justificar la curva con pendiente hacia
arriba la de oferta agregada a corto
plazo le voy a poner oferta agregada a
corto plazo verdad este era en las dos
justificaciones pero estaban en términos
de cómo los precios modificaba en el
producto interno bruto real va pero
también lo podemos pensar al revés
podemos pensar que el modificar la
oferta en términos de producto interno
bruto va a mover o bajar los precios o
sea básicamente ver si nos vamos tantito
más a la derecha
y aumentamos el producto interno bruto
real entonces estamos en este punto de
por acá y vamos a tener que cargar pues
cobrar más y por esa producción más alta
entonces pues vamos a ver ahorita que
eso no funciona tanto de igual o mejor
funciona como que a corto plazo o
aparenta funcionar a corto plazo pero
después como la economía se
sobrecaliente aquí ya no es tan buena
idea y para explicar esto un poco mejor
déjame dibujar por acá una barra de
productividad entonces tómate tu empresa
favorita digamos una empresa no sé de de
coches o de widgets o de lo que quieras
y supone que usualmente esta empresa en
su nivel potencial o sea en su nivel
saludable está al 85 por ciento
está produciendo aquí el 85 por ciento
entonces este es el nivel saludable el
otro 15% es pues tiempo que las máquinas
necesitan descansar tiempo de
mantenimiento vacaciones de los
empleados y así entonces no está
produciendo todo lo que puede producir
pero esto es saludable pero qué sucede
si de repente no se el gobierno entra en
una guerra y empieza a solicitar muchas
computadoras y empieza a solicitar
muchos tanques muchos helicópteros
empieza a requerir más gastos y lo que
sea entonces qué va a suceder con las
empresas pues las empresas de cualquier
formación negocios verdad y el objetivo
de un negocio es generar ganancias
entonces como ahorita le están pidiendo
más y más cosas pues es un muy buen
momento para producir mucho y no sólo
eso sino también para aumentar sus
precios y porque aumentarían los precios
pues porque ahora tienen pues que
justificar algunas algunos gastos verdad
van a tener que pagarles porque estas
empresas van a tener que postergar su
mantenimiento van a tener que pagarle a
sus empleados horas extras de hecho muy
seguramente en el contrato bien
estipulado que si los empleados trabajan
horas extras se les tiene que pagar más
y no sólo proporcionalmente sino
bastante más entonces pues por esta
razón va a aumentar el precio va a
aumentar el precio momentáneamente las
empresas y pues van a pensar que por el
momento van a ganar más pero de repente
eso se va a convertir en una alta de
precios a nivel macroeconómico y pues
realmente no no van a acabar ganando
tanto si al menos no van a acabar
ganando tanto digamos por unidad
entonces esta es otra forma de ver esta
curva de acá la de oferta agregada a
corto plazo no en términos de cómo mover
el precio modifica el producto interno
bruto sino al revés cómo mover el
producto interno bruto real modifica el
precio de acá y de hecho podemos
regresar al vídeo pasado donde estábamos
hablando
de la inflación de eeuu en 1960 y
podemos ver que en realidad no
necesitamos todo el modelo de demanda
agregada oferta agregada para entender
por qué se generó inflación en esta
época porque empezó a ver una alza de
precios y lo que sea y más o menos las
razones es la siguiente o sea en vista
de las razones explicadas acá abajo más
o menos la razón es la siguiente la
razón es que acá arriba ya teníamos una
economía muy calentada verdad la región
f kennedy con un desempleo muy bajo una
inflación muy baja ya era una economía
que estaba funcionando muy bien pero
cuando llega lyndon baines johnson se le
sigue pidiendo más y más a la economía
entonces él empieza a solicitar pues
muchos tanques de guerra muchas armas
muchas cosas en términos de tecnología y
de salud empieza a haber un gran gasto
luego además hay programas sociales y
entonces qué sucede las empresas dicen
wow wow espérame tantito y así me vas a
empezar a pedir tantas cosas necesita
aumentar te los precios porque estoy
trabajando arriba de mi capacidad si el
desempleo está como el 34 por ciento
entonces básicamente yo estoy trabajando
al 97 96 por ciento entonces como tengo
que trabajar
voy a aumentar los precios qué sucede
después de esos precios que eran altos
la economía se vuelve muy buena este
nivel de economía es insustentable no
puede seguir produciendo a este ritmo
todo el tiempo y así la producción
regresa a la normalidad pero nos
quedamos con la inflación vale entonces
está de acá es otra forma de ver la
curva de oferta agregada a corto plazo y
es pensando como el producto interno
bruto real al moverse modifica los
precios